et pour en parler nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
pierre laurent sénateur pcf de paris
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous on a entendu c'est la
grogne des élus qui dénoncent un grand
bazar sur le terrain martine aubry la
maire de lille qu'on a écouté il ya
quelques secondes demande au
gouvernement de dire la vérité sur ce
monde va être sans cette pénurie le
gouvernement n'est pas claire vont nous
mentir et pierre laurent s'est pas que
le gouvernement augmente mais je pense
qu'il manque de transparence et sur les
difficultés rencontrées sur la situation
réelle et depuis le début mais ça dure
depuis des mois
il associe très peu ou quasiment pas les
les élus locaux qui à chaque fois se
retrouvent dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles avec une forte
demande de la population et sans avoir
les moyens d'y répondre
qui a effectivement beaucoup
d'inquiétude mais je pense qu'il faut
mettre le doigt sur le vrai problème
nous sommes désarmés industriellement
nous sommes dépendants industriellement
et ça depuis depuis longtemps donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien que selon qu un
finder va nous livrer vite rapidement ou
pas eh bien ça a des conséquences très
importantes sur la suite
en même temps on sait depuis le début
qu'on n'aura pas assez de vaccins pour
vacciner rapidement tout le monde mais
raison de plus pour dire les choses les
mettre sur la table
associer tout le monde et ça n'est pas
ce qui n'est fait ce qui est fait donc
évidemment ça crée un sentiment de
mauvaise organisation de désorganisation
et ça inquiète la population dans un
moment où vous l'avez dit on a engagé
dans une course de vitesse contre le
contrôle coville bertrand legrand votre
regard de médecins sur ceux entre
guillemets bazar enfin d'ailleurs est ce
que vous êtes vous d'accord avec ce
diagnostic manifestement c'est un petit
peu compliqué sur sur le terrain on est
trop sévère ça va s'améliorer dans les
prochains jours selon vous
non je partage le diagnostic en réalité
on a un problème de transparence qui est
majeure on nous a dit qu'il y avait eu
cinq cent mille doses par semaine qui
avaient été livrés donc on devrait être
à un million cinq cent mille doses en
stock en ce moment et on en a injecté à
à peine entre 200 et 300 fin j'ai pas
les derniers jeux les déçus du jour
peut-être 400 et on voit bien que tous
les centres sont restreints très
fortement en nombre de doses donc en
fait on nous a mobilisés parce que c'est
ce qu'on ne comprend pas un
moi personnellement depuis deux semaines
je suis sur le pont pour transformer mon
cabinet en centre de vaccination j'ai
d'abord dans un premier temps d'une
première copine qui était trop modeste
on m'a demandé de tripler le nombre de
personnes à vacciner et au bout de deux
semaines même pas quelques jours après
m'avoir dit que ce n'était pas assez
on me dit ben non on va pas l'ouvrir
tout court parce qu'on n'a pas des doses
et on se rend compte que les deux qui
étaient promises ne sont pas arrivés sur
le territoire et celles qui ont été
annoncées ne sont manifestement ni dans
les congélateurs n'y prêtait à être
injectés donc on n'a clairement pas les
doses ou alors elles ne sont pas
délivrés et donc on est pour qu acheter
cette espèce de deux problématiques
on va essayer de faire une file
d'engorgement où on va dire orne élargi
la vaccination mais comme on n'a pas les
doses du coup tout le monde va
s'engorger dessus et après on dira c'est
la faute de ceux qui injecte qui sont
pas disponibles est pas capable
d'injecter et on voit bien le piège
politique qui se referme sur les
médecins et sur les médecins
généralistes notamment
on nous a pas fourni dose on nous a
demandé d'investir dans nos cabinets
pour se mettre en ordre de bataille et
au final l'hospital au centrisme et les
fonctionnaires vont permettre de garder
un silence total sur le nombre de doses
il faut une transparence parfaite sur le
nombre de doses qui ont été livrés et
quand elles seront livrés parce que
manifestement nous aurons le bon nombre
de doses mais probablement pas en
janvier pierre laurent il ya deux idées
un que
nous propose bertrand legrand les doses
sont elles sur le territoire si oui ou
non vous sont elles et pourquoi ne sont
elles pas approvisionnée ou alors elles
ne sont tout simplement pas sur le
territoire parce qu'il y a un problème
avec l'union européenne on a vu des pays
alors certes qui paient plus cher
ils seraient les etats-unis qui ont
davantage de vaccins que les pays de
l'union européenne non mais probablement
qu'on cumule où pullulent les problèmes
il ya un problème
enfin il faudrait y voir plus clair mais
il ya très probablement un problème
d'approvisionnement et on est et je le
répète extrêmement dépendants parce que
bon on n'en parle pas assez mais on a
quand même un très grand groupe
pharmaceutique sanofi qui est pour le
moment semble-t-il complètement au en or
les clous en tout cas qui est pas au
rendez vous un star aujourd'hui qui a
supprimé des postes aujourd'hui en
nombre chez sanofi aujourd'hui donc on
se désarme industriellement de ce côté
là et on reprend pas la main mais ça
fait des années que ça dure sur la
politique industrielle du médicament en
france au contraire mais il ya aussi
probablement des problèmes logistiques
l'état à tous les niveaux s'est
affaiblie visiblement la logistique ne
fonctionne très mal et on fait appel
alors une fois on fait appel aux
collectivités locales ou à d'autres mais
tout ça sans une organisation
manifestement optimale et je le répète
on n'associe pas assez les premiers
intéressés donc on leur demande de se
mobiliser mais sans les associer à la
construction la stratégie vaccinale
donc tout ça ne fonctionne pas mais je
répète qu' on a eu un débat au parlement
en décembre sur la stratégie vaccinale
le gouvernement est venu devant le
parlement
toutes ces questions sans aucune
exception ont été posées par nous et par
d'autres et le gouvernement nous a dit
il n'y a pas de problème on maîtrise
tout donc là c'est pas possible de se
retrouver dans cette situation parce que
ça fait la troisième fois depuis le
début
hugo vide qu'on est face à un
gouvernement qui nous dit on va
maîtriser la situation et qu'ils la
maîtrisent pas du tout donc à quelque
chose qui va pas dans la conduite des
affaires
il faut changer aussi la mode de
gouvernance de la crise dans son
ensemble pour permettre de résoudre ces
problèmes
bertrand legrand on le constate en tout
cas de rentrer dans les études d'opinion
de plus en plus de français souhaitent
se faire vacciner 1 52% +14 points par
rapport au week-end dernier comment
réagissent vos patients justement quand
vous leur dites eh bien nous on n'a pas
assez de doses
ça se passe comment survint le terrain
dans votre cabinet par exemple sur le
terrain nous jusqu'à ya encore quarante
huit heures on devait ouvrir un centre
que un centre de vaccination qui
permettrait de faire entre 1200 et 3400
vaccinations par jour dans un cabinet de
deux médecins généralistes 4
administratif une assistante donc
jusqu'à il ya 48 heures on a expliqué
aux gens pourquoi on réorganiser les
choses de manière à ce que ça puisse
fonctionner et qu'on soit efficace et
non pas à mettre 10 médecins pour faire
300 vaccins et donc du coup les mais
patience vous attendent à ce que j'ai
des doses pour le faire puisque c'est ce
qu'a d'efficace la problématique fait
qu' on ne me livre pas ses doses tout
simplement
donc je n'ai pas de doses mais rassurez
vous il ya eu 30 doses de vivre et pas
très loin à côté de chez moi à l'hôpital
est une des files d'attentes qui fait
émerger de plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui du coup voulait faire le
vaccin c'est ça le problème si vous
voulez un moment donné ou si on donne
des doses à des gens qui n'arrivent pas
à les injecter en masse et que on
interdit ceux qui peuvent les injecteurs
en masse de les injecter il faut bien
avoir une raison c'est qu'on a pas là on
appelle stücki faire alors autre
polémique du jour scène sur les masques
le haut conseil de sécurité un public
recommande maintenant de ne plus
utiliser de masque en tissu et la
distanciation sociale qui passa à 2 m le
port du masque en extérieur saad mais
théoriquement freiner l'épidémie en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on nous a dit
les français s'interrogent grandement
masse tissu masques chirurgicaux ça a
servi à quelque chose pierre laurent où
on navigue à vue et c'est bien normal
quelle est votre lecture de cette
confusion régnant d'abord c'est pas
c'est pas moi qui devrait répondre à
cette question là c'est d'abord des
médecins qui doivent apporter ce type de
réponse et et nous les responsables
politiques les écouter et probablement
les écouter davantage pour prendre les
bonnes décisions
on y semble qu'il ya tout un tas de
recommandations médicales qui sont plus
ou moins écoutés et parfois assez mal
écouté par le gouvernement ce qui
conduit à des variations il peut y avoir
des évolutions dans la stratégie
sanitaire parce qu'on apprend des choses
au fur et à mesure sur les modes de
contagion mais le problème c'est que
dans le dispositif qu'on a actuellement
ni les parlementaires ni les élus locaux
et ni on l'entend avec monsieur avec le
médecin qui est avec nous un nid les
médecins qui sont sur le terrain et
d'autres qui nous le disent à l'hôpital
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent qu'ils
ne sont pas écoutés pas associée donc au
bout d'un moment je crois que il faut je
le répète il faut revoir la manière dont
on conçoit tout ça sur les masques moi
si on me disait hier il faut une
distance de temps on me dit aujourd'hui
il en faut une impôts plus grande
vous savez les gens d'une manière
générale contrairement à ce qu'on a dit
parfois sont dans l'ensemble extrêmement
extrêmement discipliné il essaye de
suivre les consignes qui leur sont
données il essaye de les comprendre
c'est pas toujours très facile parce que
ça pèse aussi sur le moral de tout le
monde mais les gens là pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya un problème avec les vaccins
parce que le gouvernement a dit on
vaccine tous ceux qui ont plus de 75 ans
et tous les plus fragiles donc les gens
demandent à être vaccinés c'est bien
normal puisque c'est le gouvernement qui
a donné le signal de cette vaccination
le problème c'est que les vaccins sont
pas au rendez vous bertrand legrand le
mot de la fin sur 7
affaire de masse quand on sait qu'en
bavière où ils sont passés ou ffp2
obligatoire on s'est trompé là encore de
stratégie
quelle est votre réaction je vais rester
relativement constant j'avais publié une
vidéo en mars qui expliquer la
différence entre un masque ffp2 et un
masque chirurgical j'avais dénoncé en
mars qu'il fallait mettre des masques
ffp2 qu'il fallait commander des masques
ffp2 j'avais pas imaginer qu'on hausse
mais de faire des masques en tissu bon
on l'a on l'a quand même fait faute de
mieux
c'était moins pire qu'autre chose ce
qu'elle est incroyable c'est de se dire
que pendant tous ces mois où on a été
livré des masques chirurgicaux et des
masques ffp2 on n'est pas réussi à
passer outre cette espèce de vision
politique de dire à des gens qui avaient
très travaillée que féfé la couture pour
ses masques en tissu que non
effectivement scientifiquement parlant
il valait mieux quand même un
chirurgicale qu'un masque en tissu et
qui valait mieux un ffp2 plutôt qu'un
masque chirurgical
mais ça c'est une question de courage
politique et puis de stock mais
manifestement giraud payet comprendre
grand chose en politique
vous n'êtes pas le seul merci gilles
bertrand de grands verres si pierre
laurent d'avoir été avec nous